Irène Chagot propose voyage sans
passeport Fidji île du soleil de
et voici laa petit village de l'Î de
vivre dans un Bour Bour c'est le nom
queon donne à une case laa est une
plisante ch ma en guise de petitjeuner
vousurez quel noix de coco fra un régime
ban des papes des Mang des avocats et
pour orner l'ensemble pour faire joli
quelques
coquill làb les femmes livrent à la
pêche c'est une comme une autre deire
March
et dans les EAU laiteuses bordant la
Kamba elles attrapent de petits
poissons un coup de dents sur la tête
c'est le seul moyen de les bien tuer
paraît-il pour se préserver de la
réverbération ces femmes s'enduisent le
visage au noir de suis imbibé d'huile de
coco regardez bien vous le remarquerez
facilement
voyez-v sur ce visage ça se remarque
particulièrement j'ai vu comment elle
procède
elle
plonge muni de lunettes et rapporte le
repas du jour ou du
lendemain
et on les prépare pour les mettre à
mariner dans du jus de citron c'est
ainsi que ces petits poissons sont
conservés et
préparés les gros poissons eux se
trouvent dans les pass ou dans le
bleu c'est-à-dire en dehors de la
barrière du récif an les ates autrement
dit dans l'océan
lui-même voici un dag àa sorte d'énorme
poisson perroquet aux couleurs
ravissante son crâne est orné d'une
bosse splendide du
reste ce poisson pèse 104
livres et il fut suivant la coutume
offert par Schwart au chef du
village geste qui lui valut
l'autorisation de tourner les images de
danse qui vont
suiv le chef du village fait ce que bon
lui semble de son
poisson le plus souvent il le partage
fort équitablement entre tout le
monde ramaura le roi de ce village
déclara une semaine de fête en l'honneur
du poisson et pour se faire convoqua non
seulement les danseurs et danseuses de
la Cambo mais également ceux des îles
environnantes et commença la répétition
parce que là-bas chaque village a son
folklore si j'ose dire c'est et chaque
village a aussi son professeur et l'on
répète inlassablement jusqu'à la
perfection on n'improvise pas on
répète et puis le jour J
arrive et commence les
danses celle-ci
auquel succède celle de vamaga
Lola le roi ramoura est un parfait
gentlem et pour ne rien vous cacher il a
été élevé à
oxfis au dans féminine on succédé C des
hommes et c'est d' très martial qu'ils
ont interprété leur fameuse danse des
harpons de
guerre
aungawawaeang
naukanaain
Naana i
nguaka
naaani
wo na Sawa na
Ngana
na
et sans transition rendons-nous à Suva
capitale des î
fi c'est là que font escale les grands
courrier venus d'Europe des États-Unis
d'Australie ou d'extrême
orient et regardez bien est rempli
d'Indiens pour 137000 fidgiens il y a
164000 indiens ici à Tahiti le commerce
de détail est entre les mains des
chinois au Fidji il est entre celle des
Indiens les chauffeurs de taxi sont
indiens les barmen sont indiens les
serveurs les cultivateurs également
quant au fidiens mon Dieu bien ils
s'occupent du copra qu'ils vont vendre
chez un indien de chez lequel ils
sortent à seul fin de se rendre chez un
autre indien pour dépenser l'argent payé
par le premier
indien à Suva quand un bateau arrive des
marchands ambulants offrent aux
touristes du corail hélas dirais-je
peinture lurée il est présenté dans ces
petits paniers que vous voyez
là petit panier
tressé et ce petit panier plein vaut un
nouveau franc c'est tout de même
extrêmement B
marché Coro à la délicate ciselure
auquelle la couleur ajoutée enlève
quelque
chose et à qui leur couleur blanche
naturel comme celui-ci va à
Raville
et toujours sans vraie transition
passons des FIDI au royaume de
tong n alofa en est la capitale un
solide traité d'amitié datant de 1901
l'unit à l'Angleterre mais sans plus et
sa souveraine en est sa Majesté la Reine
salotte que vous connaissez tous la
reine possède sa clique personnelle qui
va de ce pas l'accueillir
puisqu'elle rentre d'un
voyage le ya de Sa Majesté s'apprête à
jeter
l'encre ses amis ses invités
arrivent voici le ya il
approche
tout est fin prêt pour l'accueil de la
reine on jette l'encre et les
Amar la
passerelle la voiture de Sa
Majesté la
police qui fait
la clique qui joue le drapeau qui
flotte un qui a oublié ses
souliers et Sa Majesté en
personne Sa Majesté la Reine salotte est
la plus grande reine du monde elle
mesure 1 M90
elle est réputée pour sa
gentillesse et le charme de son
sourire
reine infatigable à peine rentré dans
son palais que vous apercevez à travers
ses arbres pour y embrasser ses petits
enfants
elle repart vers d'autres tâches dont
les plus grandes sont toujours de
soulager les misères des pauvres gens
dans le village natal de la reine
salotte à colov existe de nombreux
arbres des arbres de fer où pulul des
chauv-souris qui sont exclusivement
réservé à la table de Sa Majesté
personne d'autre n'a le droit d'y
toucher elles sont tou ces charmantes
bestioles se nourrissent de fleurs de
fruits ce qui en rend leur chair
délicieuse paraîil
cet arbre au feuilles vivant à un aspect
extraordinaire on croirait sorti d'un
compte de
sorcière
cette partie du Pacifique qui semble si
calme et
trompeuse car le long de la côte se
trouve quelques grottes profondes rongé
sans cesse par l'assaut des
vagues et souvent ici le Pacifique se
déchaîne il ne faut pas oublier qu'une
faux sous-marines les plus profondes du
monde se trouvent au
Tonga plus de 9000 m le Pacifique trompe
son monde
voyez-vous Irène Chagot vous a proposé
voyage sans passeport cette émission a
été réalisée avec le concours de Marcel
ey Schwartz et le Solange pter montage
pierremichel Ray son Annique vedy script
Lucette Andr illustration sonore
Dominique
paladil